oh hello my name is Caleb Denby and
welcome back to game review today we're
gonna be going over a game from the Tata
Steel Masters Tournament that's going on
right now and this one is between one of
America's up-and-coming superstar chess
players Geoffrey Zhang and your Devon
Forrest Geoffrey managed to win this
game
and let's see how he did it it was
actually a very interesting one game
started
efore c5 Knight f3 d6 and Bishop b5
check so of course Bishop e5 is one of
the most popular lines for white against
the Sicilian these days and the reason
for that is this Bishop often ends up
looking a little bit you know looking a
little bit out of place it's difficult
to find a home for this Bishop sometimes
and so quite often the white players as
in this game will trade it off early
using this Bishop b5 and that's exactly
what happens here and now Geoffrey plays
this move c4 kind of committing to a
Maroc C bind a style of position and
we'll see very very quickly that he
arrives at just that without too much
hassle Knight f6 Knight c3 g6 and now
after D for C takes d4 Knight takes d4
and Bishop g7 you can really see the
structure has started to take shape so
of course you can imagine if a bishop
we're still in the f1 square here it
wouldn't be the happiest piece it'd be
stuck behind the C pawn in this epon and
eventually maybe after White's next move
f3 it would not even have this open
diagonal to its name so it makes a lot
of sense for white to get rid of this
Bishop early on in this opening black
continues by castling white plays Bishop
e3 knight c6 castles Queen d3 rook FC 8
and b3 and this is all pretty well known
territory this is this is nothing new so
far but blacks next move is actually a
very ambitious attempt to solve all of
blacks problems at once
just talking a little bit about the the
general structure of maroc see blind
positions we're really focusing in on
this d5 square this is the point of
whites play he wants to prevent black
from ever playing this move d5 and
meanwhile from the black point of view
Malec does have quite a bit less space
but he has pretty much too freeing moves
if he can ever play d5 he's really
really happy and all of his problems
will be solved but in order in order to
achieve that he really needs to loosen
White's grip on this square and that's
generally done with the move that black
played in the game b5 now of course this
move looks a little bit strange it looks
as though black is is simply sacrificing
a pawn here and in some sense he is but
it's not as simple as as it might seem
historically I want to mention the move
Queen d8 has seen some play there's a
Topalov game as well as a Maxine the
Sheila Ralph came in this with this move
and the reason for Queen d8 is mostly to
vacate this square so 97 and Knight c5
can come through and the game would
continue but black really would still
have these these spatial problems and
eventually black is going to try to play
this move B 5 so if b5 works here for
black it's actually very theoretically
important because now this would mean
the black can solve all of his problems
immediately without any hassle he's
playing all of the breaks he needs but
unfortunately for him Jeffry managed
actually caused some problems
Geoffrey did capture this pawn now
Knight e5 was your choice Queen d2
keeping an eye on this night and now d5
and so we see black like I said is
trying to solve all of his problems at
once play all of the pawn breaks as soon
as you can Knight takes d5 this Jeffries
move Knight takes d5 he takes d5 and now
black does recapture this pawn on b5 and
if we do take quick stock of the pawns
it's actually six to five and whites
favor white for the moment has this
extra deep on but the question is going
to be if he can really keep keep this
pawn and it's it's actually a pretty
interesting question
Geoffrey plays the move rook a d1 which
is a very tricky move actually
it seems as though at first black can
really capture this pawn without any any
hassle just Queen takes d5 but here
Jeffery actually has a very important
move to maintain an advantage and I
won't ask you to find it at home because
it's actually a very very difficult move
it's simply Queen e2 and while you might
you know think this move is very very
natural the point behind it is it's
pretty subtle right first of all we're
attacking this pawn but the deeper point
is if B for the very natural choice to
keep this pun defended we're going to
play Knight f5 and pick up the very
important dark-squared bishop and once
this bishop falls off the board black is
actually going to be in a little bit of
danger again can imagine Queen e6 and
Knight takes bishop King takes bishop
bishop d4 and these dark squares are
actually looking pretty weak you have to
play f6 and now things like f4 are going
to come things like rook e1 there's
going to be pressure on this a pawn and
it would be very very uncomfortable for
black so all of that is to say rook a d1
a very tricky move delaying blacks
ability to recapture this pawn the game
continued with b4 and now Geoffrey plays
Queen e2 anyways
perhaps slightly better might have been
the move 92 now no need for all these
tricks whites just gonna try to keep the
pawn but Queen e2 not a bad move and
rooks III was black's choice and this
move is actually a bit of a mistake of
course if black were to capture here he
would transpose into the previous line
but you can actually solve this problem
of 9f5 relatively easily simply by
moving this bishop off of g7 now with
the Bishop on f6 black would want to
recapture here and be totally totally
fine
instead the rook c3 Bishop f2 and now
Bishop f6 but now we really see a key
difference between the first line in
this line and that difference is that
this work has been put onto a pretty bad
square actually c3 is not where it wants
to be and because this work is on c3 we
can play Knight b5 and hit this rook
with tempo
so this Rick has to move and now Jeffrey
has the time to play a very annoying
move d6 d6 trying to trade this pawn off
for the pawn on e7 and solidify White's
advantage of having the extra pawn but
we'll see in the game it's not quite so
simple rook a b8 does attack the knight
the Knight has to move the knight comes
to c7 and now black does get the pawn
back but in return White's pieces have
been greatly improved this Knight is on
an excellent outpost on d5 this pawn is
going to be forever weak on d6 in fact
black might rather not have this pawn at
all just to free up his pieces a little
bit there's serious dark-squared
weaknesses around this King and Geoffrey
is going to be doing very very well in
this position black played bishop d8 and
now it's actually a relatively easy game
for white to win here and it's a little
bit shocking that Geoffrey didn't play
the the simplest plans and instead
really gave his opponent an opportunity
to get back into the game Geoffrey's
choice was f4 but much simpler is to
just play rook d4 double rooks on the D
file and the fact of the matter is all
of these ponds are going to fall for
black there's just no good way to defend
all of these weaknesses for example you
can try to defend with Queen b7 white is
in no rush though to do anything you can
simply play a move like 93 you're
hitting this pawn this pawn is for every
week as well and and why it's just going
to be much much better instead though
this move f4 gives black an opportunity
to come back into the game by playing
Knight g4 now this Bishop is is a little
bit uncomfortable it's a very very
powerful piece and you definitely don't
want to trade it for the night so Bishop
d4 is forced and now after rook b5 this
this Knight is actually slightly
uncomfortable you have to defend it with
Queen f3
you can also defend it by making a
recruiting move but Queen f3 is the most
natural now Queen f5 though that's
another attacker to the knight rook e1
Geoffrey chooses
defend it tactically of course this
threatens a checkmate bishop age 4 is
black choice and now after Bishop b2
black is actually equal izing if he
plays accurately here the move Queen c2
is actually what he needs to be doing
putting more pressure along this second
rank there's no good way to evict this
Queen due to the awkward placement of
White's rooks and really white has
nothing better than to play 97 and trade
off this star Knight for this night on
g4 and then all pieces are hanging and
you can imagine after queen bee - well
that hangs a rook so don't do that after
something like brick a8 ricky 7 Queen
beat to the pieces are starting to be
liquidated and this game is going to
fizzle out black however missed this
opportunity once again Queen c2 is the
movie had to play looking for counter
play and he chose to give a check as we
all are sometimes tempted to do and
after King H won his last chance to get
back into the game is to solve the
problem of this fork by playing King f8
and this looks pretty counterintuitive
because you're allowing white to capture
this rook and the line is kind of long
and tactical and tough for a human to
play I think but blacks choice bishop h4
actually loses immediately and I'll let
you at home try and find the move to
prove it for just a moment here go ahead
and pause the video if you like but okay
the answer is pawn to g3 and the fact is
this Bishop has no squares g5 is
obviously attacked f6 runs into Bishop
takes f6 when if you recapture this I'll
have a very nice fork and Bishop e7
loses to obvious reasons and Bishop d8
actually allows checkmate in one so this
Bishop is completely trapped on the h4
square and that is the end of the game
for black a few more moves were played
tonight of to check white simply
captures rook takes d5 was black's idea
getting the knight on
five for this night on f2 but now white
can simply capture the bishop and be up
a clean piece few more moves for played
and after rook c1 here black simply
resigned so actually a very impressive
game from Geoffrey here using this D
pawn to his advantage
to play moves like d6 and get his pieces
active black missed an opportunity to
come back into the game and then
Geoffrey winning a piece tactically and
it's all over
thank you very much for joining me today
on game review and I'll see you in the
next episode